okay good morning everybody and welcome
to the committee of conference for
um hb119 which is
relative to Homestead food operation
licensure and making Provisions for the
sale of meat from uninspected bison elk
or Red Deer
and
um
so I'd like to open up uh this committee
conference with the discussion of
how
the bill was amended by the Senate it
was originally
a bill which
um
ex which took out language from RSA 143
hyphen a colon 5 Section 7 which took
out the
maximum annual gross sales of 35
from the homestead food operations
RSA and the Senate then added language
having to do with the slaughter
of um elk and red deer and bison and
when it came to the house
we looked at that and had some issues
with the language that was added so
hence we had a non-concur and requested
committee conference
um
representative Bixby
had worked with
one of the Senators Senator Innis
to develop some language that was more
acceptable to the house position and
representative Bixby if you would please
explain your amendment that you're
bringing today okay so um actually I'd
like to see if
um our Senate colleagues could just give
somebody some sense of where why they
decided to put this uh their Amendment
on
um at this point rather than having it
go go through the regular regular Bill
process
well good morning and uh thanks for
having us it's good to be back in my old
committee
good to have you uh always good to be
back so uh this language was brought
into us and in reviewing it this has
been something that we've all been
looking at for many years doing these
types of things and it seemed like it
was a the language worked and it was a
good fit and we had agreement from all
of the stakeholders that they were in
general okay with this I know there were
a few concerns from Health and Human
Services but they were things that we
were able to address
and so we decided it was a good time to
put this on and bring it forward
so that is that is why it's in the bill
you see today
okay so
um when it came over to us uh we
um
we checked in with the state vet and he
said that he had some concerns about the
lack of testing for CWD brucellosis
tuberculosis and a couple of others that
I don't remember which they are right
now but
um
and that
um so that he was hesitant to uh to say
yeah this is great
um and
um at the same time we recognized that
the
um elk and deer Farmers have been
looking for some way to do Humane
Slaughter on the farm as opposed to
making and taking the essentially wild
animals to a slaughterhouse which is
highly stressful it's not good for the
animals it's not good for the meat so
um so we thought that um there should be
some way to make this work in the short
run uh but in the long run we want to
make sure that the state vets concerns
about uh disease surveillance are
sufficiently met
uh so
uh Judy and I got on uh had a a good uh
discussion with uh Senator Innis uh and
uh who I believe
um brought the language originally
that's correct
um and we came up with uh this amendment
and the basic idea uh there are three
key parts to this amendment one is to
make sure that uh the uh that the the
bill itself includes language that
indicates that uh the red the
um
Red Deer and Elk are properly enclosed
are propagated uh only from within
existing herds and
uh that are they're not brought in from
uh there are none brought in from out of
state uh and that and also that if there
are atypical deaths that those animals
on on any of those Farms if those
animals get tested for CWD so that if
there if there is CWD coming into the
state somehow uh which it could through
wild herds uh that we get an early early
warning sign of that
um so that it doesn't get into the food
supply uh the other thing is that we
want to come back and do a proper study
of how this should be done in the long
term so we set a two-year Sunset
um the sunset would would happen July
1st 2025.
um
and uh and that should give us plenty of
time to get a
um to get the uh
a a pro a more a more thoroughly
structured program up and running there
are programs Maine has a good set of
regulations on they have a two-tier
system for their um Red Deer and Elk
Farms that they have a monitoring level
and they have a level that's compliant
with the USDA certification program
uh so we could look at how they have
their structured and possibly use that
as a model
um and representative Bixby we do have
plans for a study committee
that a bill that had been passed yes
that establishes a study committee to
look at this issue yes so that that's I
believe that that the governor just
signed the uh the guy I know that the
governor just signed the budget
yesterday and I was told that that
language was put into the budget uh so
um
so that so um so ostensively when that
study committee uh is done we will have
something that will replace the at this
after the two-year Sunset yes or
actually we'll probably replace it
before the two years let's see if we'll
even reach the sunset right
representative I do have one question
sure am I trying to make sure I'm
reading this right but on the last page
page four line three this is section 7
through 10 of this actual take effect
July 1st 2025. right okay so make sure
I'm understanding this okay so it took
me a little bit to figure out what
Courtney had done yeah
I just noticed that so so let me just go
through from from start to finish so I
can and and I can be pretty quick on the
explanations uh on the first page uh so
um the new section J is basically
referencing the
um statutes that uh in the fish and game
laws and in the Aguas that uh relate to
uh propagation uh and and key and
keeping of Red Deer and Elk uh and
um and also and the and for under 420
436-24 uh there is a
um
there is a rule that says that uh in
order to uh import deer from servants
from out of state both the sending and
receiving State need to be compliant
with the uh Federal
um program for certification and New
Hampshire New Hampshire is not so
basically that that basically bans the
import of out-of-state deer until
unless we at some point are part of that
program
um
and then uh for
okay the um
that uh
that sets up that is sets up the testing
in case of an atypical death uh and then
um sections new section six adds the
definition for an atypical death and
then we get to section seven on line 16
and uh this is this has to do with the
Sun the sunset starts here
so uh in order to make the sunset what
uh OLS did was they created a
perspective amendment that would
basically put back into place the law as
it had been before this uh this
amendment this amendment takes place
okay so
um so section seven and section eight uh
deal with
um putting removing elk and red deer
from the food Protection Services
statutes and section 9 reinstates uh RSA
420 427 colon 2A uh as it was before
well as it is right now and as as it you
know prior to this bill taking effect uh
that's it will replace that so
it's kind of a bad part of me for one
second but you know we've done these a
lot with sunsets and and can't we just
say it's repealed
it's it's a lot simpler to just say that
this uh this entire change is repealed
not overwrite
the change with a new bill that goes
back to the old bill that just seems
convoluted to me so this is the way that
OLS chose to do it I did not suggest
this is the way to do it but they deemed
that this was the way to do it and they
are
uh more uh my experience is that they
are generally more knowledgeable about
the way that statutes need to be
um
uh changed then uh that I am and it not
only went through
um the drafting attorney uh Courtney
ashbach but also was reviewed by their
in their review process and they deemed
that this is this was this was the right
way to do it I'm going to trust them on
it and it it looks like it will do the
job
so I don't want to I don't want to make
any fuss about you know how they chose
to do it it looks like it's functional
thank you madam chair
um so a couple of things I
I I understand the intent of where we're
going and I would I would like to see us
get to a place where
I do have a few
um
hesitations I would say just in general
about the we want to make sure that New
Hampshire stays free of CWD and as I
understand it right now we don't have
that correct
um but it exists elsewhere in our
bordering communities so I just want to
make sure that we are not opening the
door for
that and it is not necessarily something
you can tell exists by looking at an
animal just a quick correction we do not
have any neighboring states with CWD
either
um the closest state that is actively
monitoring because of uh
outbreak years ago is New York
nothing bordering us is uh has got CD WD
or has had any cases thanks for the
correction representative but and I also
think there are a few
um cases being monitored in Canada as
well so I just want to make sure that we
are
it is a neurodegenerative disease that
is transferable to humans so I just want
to make sure that we're proceeding with
something that well on our on Farm
Slaughter isn't going to promote that
that would happen by moving either
naturally or bringing in animals and I
think we've taken care of that
and I'm fine with that I just wanted to
make sure I understood what we were
putting in this amendment because it
does seem like a backwards way of doing
it but I guess I get it
it I when I first look at it I I said Oh
shoot
what did Courtney do well and then and
then I and then I read it more carefully
and I raised oh okay that's how she did
it and I guess that's how she would have
had to do it I I can understand why she
did it that way it's
um and
um
so um my fellow Senate colleagues
understanding what we're what we're
doing here yeah okay
um and I think that uh it can one reason
why it can't simply be well just repeal
the thing is that it didn't come through
as an individual bill it's it it it came
through as an amendment to a uh to
another bill good point
okay and we wouldn't want we wouldn't
and so if the whole bill bill got
refueled then we'd lose the the the
getting rid of the cap on the homestead
Foods uh so can we have 10 seconds here
sure sure
okay okay so um I guess we individually
have to vote as to whether we accept the
amendment and um I think the house
side's in the Senate side each vote so
yeah yeah separately all right so if we
vote I move we accept the amendment
uh I second
and um all those in favor
aye aye
I'll move the amendment
to 194h all in favor
aye aye any opposed seeing none Okay so
we've adopted this amendment to this
bill and uh are we now all in agreement
uh for this committee conference
um to uh concur with hb119 as amended
yes yes yes okay we see to the house
position with the amendment okay
I guess we are adjourned then thank you
thank you
all right well it wasn't four minutes
[Laughter]
all right so okay
um oh before we leave oh shoot
foreign
I know I I've already adjourned this but
is this something we can put on consent
huh
we just have to go sign the report in
the clerk's office okay so and uh please
keep an eye on your email to see when
they will have it ready to have your
signature
so next one is it uh 9 30.
something
say it's ten times
do you enjoy it 10 times more
live today the 12th the last five today
although this year it seems like there's
less cocs than I've seen in the past
yeah
okay I'm
um hello
okay
um good morning everybody
I'm going to open up our committee
conference this morning for hb221
um this is relative to the acquisition
of our of agricultural land development
rights relative to Advanced deposit
account wagering and relative to the use
of game cameras
um hb221
originally
um went to the Senate with language that
clarified the statutes for land
acquisition and development rights in
conservation land making a change to RSA
432 colon 22. and the Senate added in
amendments to occlude include Property
Owners rights with regard to defining
and regulating game camera use on
private property for purposes of taking
forbearing animals which was language in
sb14
a house approved language
and also
added in a language from sb190 Advanced
deposit wagering on paramutual betting
on horse racing and authorizing a
Lottery Commission to adopt rules
governing the license and regulation of
such Wagers when it came to the house we
decided to non-concur
based on some of the additions that the
senate had made
and so we are here today to iron that
out
and I
um
one of the things that one of the
sticking points was particularly the
advanced deposit wagering language which
was retained SB 190 was retained in the
Ways and Means Committee in the house
and I don't know if representative
Sanborn if you'd like to speak to that
for a moment
thank you madam chair yes I'm here
representing the unanimous bipartisan
position of the ways and means house
committee to retain Senate Bill 190. uh
we have no problem with the other two
bills that are attached to House Bill
221 but we would like to continue to
work on Senate Bill 190 in-house Ways
and Means and we plan to do so this fall
so we'd very much like to see this
unattached to this Christmas tree and
allowed to be worked on on its own okay
I have brought an amendment to that to
that end
2023-2188h which strips out that
language from SB 190 from the bill that
came to us from the Senate and would
like Senate to make comment on that
would you be amenable to
adopting this amendment which removes
the advanced wagering deposit language
let me ask my colleagues what are your
thoughts yeah that's the house version
we're good with that who set up a 14 to
70 in this kill right here so yeah okay
so I you know we're obviously here to
represent the Senate position and we had
added the two amendments the game camera
language and the advanced deposit
wagering
the uh you know certainly the the Senate
position as we'd like to keep that in
there but we understand that it's a a
point of contention with the house and
um we certainly if our value the
underlying Bill and has spent the the
original 221 and we certainly value the
game camera language that was the
addition
um
everyone where my colleagues are I mean
I guess we can consider if
do we need to caucus or are you all you
know I'm good you're all okay with that
we're all good well we will accept the
amendment the uh I just would say that
our preference would have been to have
had this language move through well we
certainly respect Ways and Means and
you're retaining of of that language we
would we would like to have had it go
through and it was very important to um
the Attorney General into the Lottery
Commission but I guess that's gonna rest
on your shoulders now to make sure you
get something through this fall and
satisfied the need that they expressed
to us that was so important which is why
we added it to this bill
absolutely uh we didn't hear that it was
urgent actually in our committee and I
checked with all of our members on that
um but we we do think it's important and
we'll absolutely be working on it this
fall thank you we appreciate that
commitment representative Bixby yeah I'd
just like to note that um the Senate uh
made a a small change to the underlying
bill on 221 which was to add one member
to the oversight committee or commission
and uh that is something that we are
entirely fine with
um and uh we are fine with having the
game camera bill on this because we
think the game camera is very important
uh so I think that um what we should do
is a seed to the Senate position with
the amendment as presented by a
representative Aaron
so we'll uh representative spleen yeah I
wanted to uh add that I did review the
language that the Senate added and also
with the language in this amendment they
all match with our house position of
what we passed with uh the uh compromise
language that we were able to come up
with for the game camera bill in sb14 so
I'm good with it and I have no problem
at all uh moving forward with that thank
you
well if I could give one just
yeah okay so you don't need to make it a
vote you don't think
well I would like one quick response for
uh to uh representative Bixby I did add
a a another position to the board
because I don't like even boards I think
it was eight yeah yeah because I didn't
want the ability to be a tie and I
thought an additional farmer member on
the board would bring some great
perspective to these land easements
yeah
so um
for for our house members here I move we
adopt um Amendment
2023-2188h I'll second that
all those in favor
aye
and for the Senate I'll move the
amendment we need to vote on it
except we're doing it all right we're
good
okay
so uh according to our committee
conference here we have uh agreed to
adopt
um Amendment
2023-2188h and now concur with this
spell yeah verily thank you and I'd
adjourn this meeting thanks for your
work thank you good job Judy can we
throw that on consent too oh we can we
will throw that on consent yeah that
sounds good thank you
I got a text from the clerk he said that
yes we can on the house side we can do
consent yeah
yeah thank you have a great day
[Music]
yeah um the I will I'll go down to uh
OLS now and um they will OLS will let
everybody know when the committee report
is available to be signed
ish
I will now open the committee conference
on HB 442
the House and Senate being unable to
agree on the versions of the bill uh we
are now going to have some discussion
over how we can come to an agreement
between the two bodies and push
something forward so that we can
actually take action
um relatively soon especially given that
one of the findings that was in the
Senate version is that uh
it's an issue that needs to be addressed
very quickly
um
I am going to
lay out
some of the issues that I found with the
Senate version which allowed us to non-
concur that being that I like what the
Senate did uh
we understand the diving for Lobster's
part is out that's not an issue we'll
address that another day but as far as
the cleanup goes uh allocating the
funding is good I think there needs to
be more guard rails around how that
funding is used to make sure it's used
appropriately
one of the things that we would not want
to see is just the money spent to send
some lobsterman out in their boats
dragging the hooks to try to come up and
tell us that they didn't find anything
we want to make sure there's a good
faith effort to uh to actually retrieve
the traps that we know are out there and
that the money is being spent to the
ends of removing this junk from the
waters I'm going to now
plus the other thing was that it doesn't
start till 2024 with any kind of cleanup
we didn't even say in the beginning of
2024 in the bill it just says three
times in 2024 and three times in 2025.
and and if one of the findings is that
there's an immediate need to address the
issue waiting till sometime in 2024
which could be a year from now is not
really addressing the issue according to
the finding so I'm going to now turn
over discussion to representative Hill
who has drafted some ideas
um that uh
he would like to see that would tighten
some of that up it doesn't remove
anything that the Senate's done it just
adds to it and then we can have
discussions based on that
all right just FYI I might have to skip
out because I'm in another Community
Conference and we're adjourned until 3
uh 35 and I'm one minute over so I'm all
yours
thanks and thanks for uh taking the time
to have this discussion with the house
the house bill passed uh 271 to 100 I
think or something somewhere in those
range what we wanted to do was take
um and hopefully come to a an agreement
here on some of the things that were
um
of most interest by the house members
which was the cleanup
um that that's what resulted in the 271
votes
I actually think that may have been the
bill that was the most bipartisan vote
that we took all year quite frankly
um aside from the unanimous votes of uh
of the budget and so on
um
so what I put together is um is some
draft language
um it had OLS put it together a couple
of things I still find that are are
problematic one is that it says it
amends the bill by replacing all after
the enacting Clause with the following
that was not the intention and that was
not what was conveyed the goal was to
keep the Senate version in place
however to address the immediacy of the
problem which which is that we currently
have and are continuing to add to the
amount of contamination in terms of
derelict fishing gear in our Coastal
Waters
um
the goal and and and subsequently to the
or in addition to that and and primarily
the concern of the diving Community
anyway is that there are animals dying
continuously from that derelict fishing
gear
uh we we have pictures here of of divers
that took a 30-minute dive and found uh
two traps with uh with animals live
animals in them and I'm sure the Senate
is aware that uh this is an ongoing
problem this is a is a worldwide problem
it seems to be a worldwide problem
everywhere except New Hampshire for some
reason
um so we're hoping that uh the Senate is
able to agree that there is urgency to
this to this problem
um
there were two what we've done in this
draft amendment is basically
um begin begin the process now not
um not take at face value the idea of
the instructions by the Senate two
fishing game to create a process to
create some kind of a program on the
hope that that's will be something that
will work next year
uh Mr chair yes representative I just
wanted to uh point out to the members
here sitting at the table on both sides
Senate and House that the amendment is
not something we can vote on now as it's
written because there are mistakes with
it it was just ideas that we want to
discuss adding drafting the amendment
that will add to the end of the Senate
side so there's two valid uh pertinent
paragraphs in that and I would like uh
representative Hill to read those so
that the members can be aware of what
the the suggestion is so we can then
move forward and discuss it so you don't
want me to just pass them out
all right we can pass them out so they
can refer to them but I'd like we can't
vote on it
um it's it's written improperly so it's
something that we can
Go Diego Senator okay fine
so if you could point out those two
sections uh
sure
um the news sections would um would deal
with um the rapid response that's needed
um we have we have people in the water
now
um and we have uh people who are capable
of of identifying where these traps are
we have pages and pages of uh of traps
that are obviously derelict traps
um
and there would be no reason for
divers to be able to begin locating
where where these traps are
and there would be no reason why the
live animals that are contained within
those traps can't be released this
summer
so representative just just for our
reference we're looking really
specifically at section two beginning on
line 15. and continuing through section
three on page two all the way over to
page line three on page three so it'd be
basically sections two and three because
my quick look it looks like the section
four and five were the parts of the
Senate bill that were already there
four and five
um so it looks like it begins on line 15
page one section two news that's where
the new the new language starts yep
um but again we're not voting on no I'm
just for us to consider right so that
we're not reading through all the things
that we don't need anything above line
15 you need to ignore because the
findings somehow got messed up in in the
drafting although I think that finding
four being added into there would not be
a bad thing which says since derelict
fishing gear contains microplastics a
possible funding source might be the
Monsanto settlement funding uh that's
just a direction of of uh a heads up as
to where some of the funding might come
from but we haven't also told them to
directed them to go ask them for money
from NOAA which we know that they can
get as well so it's not necessary but it
is a good heads up but for the purposes
of this conversation for the purposes of
this conversation we need to look at
line 15 on uh which has the
sections that he was
talking about adding in
um so so it does seem that the new
sections are as you stated referral from
15 to 15 page one to page two yep and
then it looks like the Senate language
is all the remaining oh I see what the
okay so we got mixed in there
okay I see so there's nothing no to my
knowledge there was nothing that was
taken out of the Senate language no but
something additional was added to sex to
finding three Roman numeral three which
wasn't there and somehow appeared there
which isn't it isn't a finding so it
doesn't belong there
regardless it's a Direction
so that should not be there either
uh so
from the Senate finding three said a
useful component of the cleanup effort
is in addition to stakeholders to assist
in is in the addition of stakeholders to
assist in the removal of derelict
fishing gear period
and somehow this other bit got added on
saying stakeholders assisting with the
cleanup of derelict fishing gear are
thereby authorized to physically touch
that's a Direction that's not a finding
and it doesn't belong in there that
sentence should be that whole thing
somehow crept into a finding when it
didn't belong there
so finding number four talks about a
different funding source uh one of the
possible funding sources but the bill
allocates some funding already yeah the
bill it's extends General funds correct
this is the house suggesting that we
change it would be in addition nope it
would just be additional funding sources
and that's still in here I believe
because we left the we left the
allocation of funds that the Senate put
in but we're also suggesting there's
other funds available if they need more
and in fact here here's even an article
on another funding source which is the
NOAA marine debris program
which Maine received 143 139 because
they applied for it and we have not yet
applied for any of that NOAA money but
it's being dispersed to all kinds of
States uh even Mexico even even we gave
some to Mexico from Noah uh half a
million dollars to clean up their
derelict fishing gear and such so we we
have other funding sources that could
double or triple the amount of money
that they have to work with to get the
problem solved and so we're just
throwing out if if we seed it with the
hundred thousand you have other sources
you can go get money from as well let's
go get it done and there's actually
Federal money that
um I think has been voted on an
authorized
in the millions coming to New Hampshire
specifically for Coastal cleanup
so money shouldn't be an issue in this
um
the the problem that I have as a House
member is that we're waiting
um and hoping that that a a process will
take place that could have taken place
all the way from 1971 when we cut we
have current rsas that allow this to
already exist
and Heaven
so it would seem to me urgency is needed
and direction is needed from the house
and the Senate and that's hopefully what
the amended uh draft uh Amendment to the
Senate language would would take place
we have two ideas of how this can happen
um the this the fishing game already
utilizes SurveyMonkey for a striped bass
program so there's no reason when we
couldn't adapt that to utilize for
divers to look to locate and Report
where these where these traps are
that could be happening
um
how by the weekend as far as I'm
concerned
um and uh and there's also no reason why
um these as the divers who are already
in these Waters now
um
and have been there's no reason why when
they come upon derelict traps that have
no surface buoy and or
tags that are from previous years
there's no reason why those can't be
identified and
um and opened and have the animals that
are trapped inside and will certainly
starve and die
be released
so
that's that's the um the Crux of the
additional language
is do we want to amend the Senate
language to allow
live animals that will certainly starve
to death this summer be able to be
released and those additional traps be
located and reported to the fishing game
where they exist
yes Senator thank you I have a couple of
questions one who are the defined
stakeholders that you mentioned
uh thank you
um the programs that are ongoing in
States
um bordering us
um indicate that the stakeholders are
the lobster the lobstering industry
themselves The Fish and Game the diver
the dive community and any number of
volunteers there are uh main main has an
extensive program and he came and and
one of those non-profits came and
testified to the Senate and to the house
um couldn't come to this event but uh
because he's busy pulling uh I think 415
traps out of uh Boothbay Harbor the last
weekend
um they are they are ongoing in every
state around us except
us
and in fact it has the the situation in
Maine is is a actually a good model of
how this works with cooperation but to
get to that point we need to we need to
have the stakeholders admit that there
is a problem which some of the
stakeholders have been reluctant to do
and so we need to sort of prod along the
process uh in my eyes to make sure that
we start to recognize the problem exists
we start to identify where they're
located and we start removing some of
them so yes Senator you have another
yeah I do
um in terms of the timing so let's say
this gets signed July 1st within 60 days
fishing game has to issue an RFP
then that has to be issued for 30 days
and there's a review process
how how do we
how does this make it
faster
I mean it's I think about the timing of
getting things done it looks like 2024.
pretty much I don't disagree with you
for setting up the formal program
that fish and games directed in here to
do
but in the meantime while those
processes are going on while the RFP is
out there's nothing preventing us if we
give the divers permission to go out and
locate the traps identify where they are
and report them to start Gathering that
data
first of all to gather the data of where
they're located and how extensive the
problem is but two on the second side
end of things when they encounter these
traps we need to give the divers
permission to release those animals
that's the parts that get done earlier
the formal program can't be just because
of the logistics of the whole thing as
you stated but the free portion of
having the volunteer divers providing
this information shouldn't be held up
until the program's formal we should be
having those those uh Gathering that
data now where are the traps located all
the ones we know about get them mapped
out it'll help with the crafting of the
formal program I think so is that
starting on line 29 of page one where
the divers can
right away yes
yep floating a marker to the top to show
where the Trap is located when they
encounter one
let's ask one other question
ing is it's a pilot program has Maine
issued
any data on what the results of that
program we have we have data to this
point I believe representative Hill
you've got that data right you know some
of what the they did I'll let you speak
to that thank you
thank you um
all we're talking about is one
organization at this point which was
Oceans wide
um
oceans wide w-i-d-e
um they are operating out of Boothbay
Harbor
and I think Damariscotta
I think
um and uh and they have
um
mountains of information that he left
off for us in testimony it's actually in
the Senate record as well uh of of their
work that they did over the last year
and they've continued this year they're
actually doing it as a volunteer program
with some of the high schools they're
getting students certified for scuba
they are operating very very similarly
to the to the proposal here with the
marker boys that uh that exist in this
draft language
they have reported to us that two-thirds
of the traps that they bring up
have have live animals in them
and the ones that don't have live
animals in them have
um remnants of animals in them
so that's where some of the the actual
data is coming from
um they are reporting that they have
work
um just inside Boothbay Harbor for the
rest of their career if they didn't
expand
um and they're coming up with numbers
um that are roughly what the um national
uh Oceanic and uh
what is it Oceanic
atmospheric and Association or
Administration says and of roughly the
10 percent number and that's where that
comes of 10 percent of the traps that
are do you do you remember what they
said they pulled out of Boothbay Harbor
last summer I think it was in the close
to half a million traps was it not
yeah I can't swear that it was in my
testimony but yeah I can't remember the
numbers but we do have those numbers
they are in the record in the Senate
they are in the record in the house from
the committee as well Mr chair yes
Senator we need about a 10 minute break
okay yeah we need to go have a
discussion
I got another committee at conference at
11.
sure sorry we're all jammed pretty tight
but we need we need about a 10 minute
recess we can take a 10 minute recess
um and come back at uh I call it 11 1105
1105. it said
that's fine that's fine thanks um
all right give us about 10. sure
thank you
all right we are back in committee
conference
I'm going to point out that the
committee researcher has dropped off the
testimony for the State House from
Ocean's wide
and I'm going to direct people to take a
look uh at one of the more interesting
facts because it it relates to what
we're talking about about starting to
get data gathered now and that's uh page
two d
uh subsection 4 Roman numeral four
item one survey the initial survey found
850 traps in 18 days
that was an initial survey just in the
Boothbay Harbor area
and that's kind of what we're talking
about when we say that we'd like to
um
amend the Senate's Language by adding on
something that gets us started sooner
um
we would like I think that
using our free volunteer resources of
the divers to start collecting that data
doesn't cost us anything and doesn't
need to wait for the formal program
so I want to summarize some of the
discussion that we've been having so far
because I was talking with
representative pair here and and um
there is a way to summarize this
we would like to amend the Senate's bill
to allow us to get started earlier with
the collecting of data and the freeing
of Trapped animals when and if that is
found by a diver in a trap that is
otherwise irretrievable so that the
animal doesn't die that's it and however
we find a way to come to that agreement
we would be appreciative if we can get
there
so we had a discussion when we were out
um
none of us are comfortable at this point
and adding in allowing scuba divers to
go in and touch the traps that are under
there right now we're all struggling
with that one a bit and that was one of
the things that I wanted to discuss with
the captain Eastman about the current
law and it would be contradictory and
he'll have to tell you which one it is
because I don't remember but it would be
contradictory to current law to allow
them to touch the traps that are there
and release the animals I I understand
exactly what you're saying I I get it
unless it's done under a program and
that's how that's how we'd have to do it
that's why and I we agree it's
imperative to get this program moving as
quickly as possible
one of the the thought that we had is
and I understand you're concerned about
there not being any guard wheels that we
weren't very specific about how they had
to do it just that it had to get done
so the thought that we had from the
Senate side I guess what we'd propose is
um
if you take um and require a report to
be done or them come back to us and tell
us how they're going to do this by
September 30th that gives them
essentially I mean it's just supposed to
take effect July 1st I don't know if
it's going to get signed by July 1st or
not but it's going to get signed in July
it's going to give them you know all the
rest of July August and September to
come back and say this is how we're
going to do this this is how we're going
to implement what the legislature and
the governor is directing us to do and
that gives us some guardrails on how we
do this and we'd require them to report
back to
you know the respective committees I
guess it would be energy and fish and
game on on both sides of the aisle so we
did draft up some language if you'd like
us to read it to you and tell you what
it says I would love that I think that
this is um this is a satisfying part of
the problem that I had
um and and giving us some accountability
I'm going to defer to Senator since we
both scratched down but well I was
wearing his dad
um did your handwriting improve or get
worse no
so essentially would be adding to the
Senate version of Roman 4. of section
two
and it would say the executive director
shall submit a report to the
chairpersons of the House and Senate
committees with jurisdiction over the
derelict fishing gear cleanup by
September 30th
the report shall include but not being
limited to a strategic plan for
implementing the derelict fishing gear
cleanup program including
projected priming costs
and additional funding sources
committee
a couple of quick comments
that deadline where is where is that in
relation to our if there's something in
that report we don't like and we think
that there needs to be additional
legislation filed what is our deadline
for filing that legislation for next
term we have November from our side but
I don't know what the Senate does they
have no deadline they can do whatever
but it's going to be I think ours is
September owner yeah I thought it was
sign off
and final language is November 30th and
certainly any place older bill could be
filed
to if we fear there may be concerns you
you see my point yes if there's
something that comes in with their their
proposal or their suggestion and we're
also pretty easily available to file a
late bill that's right absolutely always
approve well that's what I mean I mean
it's more on the house side I think the
ability is there if there's something in
the report we really felt compelled that
needed to be or needed to be compelled
by legislation I'm not I would hope that
there wouldn't be anything that
egregious in the well no I mean it may
not be even
that
aspect but what if something that they
want to accomplish requires us to change
an existing law if they want to do
something to implement the plan that
would be the best way to do it and it
requires us amending an RSA we need to
be able to take that action and we
certainly would have the ability to do
that but with a late file Bill if not in
the normal filing bill on the Senate
side we'd definitely be able to do that
we are always very gracious about
granting that to any member that applies
thank you secondarily
um the other the other concern I have is
that um
this was all this has all been possible
to do by you know we're giving Fish and
Game executive director until September
30th
they've had the ability since 1971 to be
able to do this so I'm not really sure
that um
I have great confidence in
you could great confidence in the in the
outcome this
the rest of the world understands that
these things exist and until we brought
this up this year all of a sudden it
seems to be first it was it was pointed
out that they don't exist and and only
begrudgingly are they agreeing to this
so it would I I hesitate to say oh yeah
well why September 30th we'll end up
with just exactly the program we need
well I would say representative that
while you may be right there may have
been a law in the books since the early
70s I would say now Fish and Game
clearly
is having the directive from the
legislature and from the governor's
office that there is this is an urgent
thing that needs to be addressed and it
needs to be addressed now this this
cleanup and we're passing this program
we're giving them the money to do it
there's a to me there's a big difference
between giving someone the authority to
do it and giving them money and saying
you will do this with the money for me
that's a much stronger message and and I
think we're making that statement as a
legislature I think the governor has
made it very clear that he has an
interest in seeing this move forward and
I think from my conversations with the
direct director Mason with Colonel
Jordan and with Captain Eastman that
they all understand that we're serious
about this and they need to be
addressing this issue I do want to
clarify just for those who haven't seen
what he's talking about with there being
a loss since 1971
um what he's referring to is uh 211
colon 72 which is um damages
determination by Department of Fish and
Game upon learning of damage to fish and
other Aquatic Life or wildlife and or
their habitat occasioned by
contamination the executive director of
the Department of Fish and Game or his
designated agent shall investigate and
determine the party responsible and it
goes on from there so it's it's talking
about contamination
which
these obviously are derelict fishing
gear whether it be Nets that got tangled
up down there are the same type of
contamination to the area as uh somebody
driving a vehicle in and plunging that
underwater too you know it's it's
um it's still contamination to their
habitat and so in a way they've had this
since 71 it wasn't targeted specifically
it was talking about any contamination
so I think now we're being more targeted
we're also providing funding and a
directive
which I think gives a little more
um strength to our argument and we've
seen the willingness of the governor to
sign it when it gets to his desk which
shows everyone involved it's a serious
issue well I would say that with uh in
my conversations in navigating through
this process no pun intended that um we
there's definitely an interest with from
the fishing industry from the lobsterman
to participate and clean up they're
doing it now they they want to do it
more they don't want their gear there if
it doesn't need to be it you know
whatever is there they're willing to
help clean up we've had that commitment
from them we've had a commitment from
fish and game that they're willing to
take this this program and implement it
and see what needs to be there and so I
I'm confident representative I realize I
understand your skepticism I fully
respect that I'm confident that we have
a plan in place or a program that I'm
hopeful is going to go forward and do
what it's supposed to
I I like what what you've done with the
draft language I have a suggestion of
something else that I think I maybe we
want to consider putting in there
because it was successful in Indonesia
when I was talking with the group from
Indonesia it's also been one of the
successful Parts about the cleanup that
they're doing in Maine with this is
preventing future
dumping of gear that's no longer wanted
by making sure that part of this funding
is used to create and sustain a
recycling program for the fishing gear
um so that we can have
two or more Central points that any
fisherman lobsterman or what have you
can dump off their unwanted gear uh and
know that it's going to be taken care of
and recycled so that there's no issue
with maybe a landfill that's rejecting
taking Lobby lobster traps and somebody
decides to drive out in a boat and dump
stuff with no longer having identifying
marks on it
um so I mean I I'm not saying that
happens here but it it has been found to
be the case when they were the
Indonesians were here talking they said
one of the biggest issues they had was
some of the coastal
contamination was actually deliberately
dumped and they've had none of that
happening since they've instituted the
recycling program
so I think that that's a component we
should also look at is preventing future
um purposeful dumping of anything by
giving that program a Kickstart as well
yes representative uh yes thank you I
have a question is the
um is there any reason that uh informal
uh
rocking and and releasing a fish can't
be done by dive groups and uh and clubs
sort of a semi-organized maybe we don't
want you know representative spleen and
myself to decide we're going scuba
diving next weekend and we'll go check
for for traps but if uh
your uh dive shop wanted to organize a
group of people that would go out and
look for traps and and release animals
you know for the for the fish and
lobsters and crabs and everything else
that are in these traps it's literally
Live Free or Die it would be nice to be
able to do something
as quickly as possible now that we're
really aware of it but but putting
together a formal program is certainly
going to take time would the chair
entertain letting Captain Eastman answer
that question I would uh if you'd like
to come up to the microphone captain
and the only reason I ask is because
there's specific rsas that prohibit it
and I want him to answer there are and
we've heard about those uh quite quite a
lot but um yeah nobody but the owner of
the Trap is allowed to touch it so go
for it
RSA
21131 is uh was adopted in in 1975 and
it says that no one except the owner or
a conservation officer can
go into that trap or move traps haul
traps anything of that nature the
wording actually is molest which is a
terrible uh way to put it but we see it
throughout the fish and game statutes
for all kinds of things we're used to it
in our committee anyway
representative
yeah thank you Mr chair and I'm glad
you're up the captain Eastman because I
did have a question
on the similar line
um you know it's unusual I did come in
here already is seeding to the Senate
position
uh usually I'm here to defend a house
position uh and all we're trying to do
is a couple of changes to speed things
up
I'm hearing that you had a conversation
with Captain Eastman earlier saying that
the no way deal is the ability referring
back to that statute
for divers to touch or Mark derelict
traps and so my question is
these are the derelict traps why can
they not touch or Mark what is the
opposition to them touching and marking
a derelict trap or an unretrievable trap
my only guess is that it's assumed that
our citizens are criminals and if we let
them touch the derelict ones now they're
going to start opening the doors of the
ones that are still connected to a buoy
I mean I'm for understanding what is the
fear
the fear is is maybe your own fears that
I've seen it snowballed where
um you know certainly anyone at this
time can see gear down there a diver
sees gear they can call and say I see a
bunch of derelict gear off a Boar's Head
in Hampton and it's at this location we
can and an officer could come and meet
with them and haul gear we I've hauled I
was the lieutenant on the Seacoast for
six and a half years and we hauled gear
that had gone derelict during the you
know the winter months in a storm and
and um you know that had a buoy attached
to it and and was not free-floating and
it's not the greatest thing to do in the
world I can tell you because it's
usually all twisted up and and it's
pretty nasty
um but certainly I mean this protects
our fishermen and that's certainly why
we you know continue to to decide with
with them and that that they you know
people cannot go into lobster traps I
had a case one time where some gear in a
freak October storm push gear up onto
Hampton Beach and
um there were people on the beach going
into the lot into the lobster traps and
stealing lobsters out of the traps and
then running back to their cars with
them and we were called and had to come
down and and take lobsters and charge
them for for this so
what was they they rolled up on the
beach everything was there and rolled up
onto the beach which is isn't uncommon
and that's why you have your your
Lobster gear pickup
um at this time so
thank you
also if I may
um there is a there was a program when I
was on the Seacoast
um that was called fishing for energy it
was a it was shouldn't knits or steel
and we had
um
dumpsters at that the Yankee Co-op also
one at the Portsmouth Co-op that was
available for fishermen to put this gear
in there and it was hauled away every
couple of months so just so that you
know I remember the name of that program
do you know if it's still running
it is it is I know that it's been a
couple months since I've been down to
the Yankee but there was a dumpster
there let me let me
um clarify it it is still available it
is through the through NOAA they have
the fishing for energy and they have the
grant programs I have no idea if New
Hampshire is participating in it or
applying for any of those grants but but
the fishing for energy program still
exists with Noah yeah they are giving
out money to every other state but ours
who are at least many
we were a part of that program for my
time on the Seacoast and I left in 2019
I've certainly still seen it there so I
know that they do pick it up it is
available to there's only one location
at the moment right we moved it around
um it was at the Portsmouth Co-op and
then at the Yankee we had some issues
where if you didn't in some areas if you
left it it would become a dumpster for
for everything else so that that became
problematic but it was at the Yankee and
that's open all the time for them and
available to dump at that location
anything else
Senator what would you like to do
there's also one additional thing in in
following up on um on representative
Walsh's comment
there's also these tags that come that
are on
um on all traps supposedly they are
color coded so there would actually be
no reason why
um a diver couldn't come across if there
was any question whether this was an
active trap or not
if the tag was uh not the the valid trap
color
um it would be easy to determine for the
diver that that is a that's been there
for for
a year
um
why we would not
release those starving animals uh in
those traps is just beyond me I um I'm
not sure what we do about that I I agree
with you
I'm not sure we can get to that end
point here today with the people that
are representing the Senate and the
house
um because it's a question that is going
to be
one that needs a lot more discussion
with a lot of members who are not
present
um just to make sure that we come to a
consensus it was in the house position
it was in the house position but so I'm
sure that on the house side we could
probably pass it but I would hate for us
to go through all this work and come up
with an idea that was going to start
working
and before we can even get a report
filed from fish and game in September
have the thing killed in the senate
floor because of
an overreach here
so I I think it's a valid idea I do I
just don't know enough about it I know
we had some conversation in that other
meeting that we had about that
and I guess uh
I would maybe encourage Captain Eastman
to perhaps
deliver to the higher ranks so perhaps
that could be part of this program is
something looking at that and
understanding if that can be implemented
into the cleanup program that there's a
way that could occur so it's just just a
thought that I would send you away with
and can I ask you to clarify those those
colors change yearly like a registration
on a car
our inspection on a car I should say
they do change yearly they have the the
license number of the lobstermen the the
number of traps that they they only get
so many plus ten percent
um the only issue is that that those
trap tags are do not come from fish and
game they come from an outside vendor
there are times when those outside
vendors have issues I know the vendor is
has had issues in years past where they
were unable to get those trap tags those
new trap tags for for months to some of
those because so they are allowed to
continue fishing with the older tag
until exactly with a waiver from Fish
and Game
but if it's
blue and you didn't have blue since
that's obviously a derelict trap if
you've got one down there with you know
a color that's two three four five years
old
that one is obviously not one that's
currently being fished outside of the
the color it would have the year of the
okay
oh yeah there's the picture there
yeah
I'll bring it over
yep with the owner and the owner's
telephone number and
and the color that looks like the uh
name tag that needs to be on the Trap
the Trap tag is actually a uh that's
like a zip tie that clicks together that
looks like the name that's the name is
required to have a name on the Trap and
on the buoy in this state
gotcha learning more every day
I'm going to propose that we take the
language that you came up with
and we make an amendment from this body
so that we can start the action with
that report coming back given the
understanding that we might need to file
legislation in September November time
frame to to allow Fish and Game to do
what they're going to come up with for
an idea
and um knowing that we've directed the
information to go back to fish and game
about how we plan to proceed I'm happy
to take the lead on drafting the
amendment I would appreciate that very
much and you can add me as a co-sponsor
on that one uh with you so essentially
how this the you're agreeing to a seed
to the Senate position with the amended
language that is what I'm going to
suggest and I'm going to have to take a
feeling from the body here do you want a
quick caucus with them
um do you think we need one or you uh
all right we might as well okay well
recess now for another five take it
you're taking a break we're going to
take a break for five minutes and we'll
be right back
in my office
yes
foreign
the patients we are back
and I think we are ready to accede to
the Senate's position with the amendment
being drafted
with the knowledge that sadly we aren't
going to be able to save the animals
that are trapped during the summer this
year
um it strikes me as ironic that we can
break a window of a car to let a dog out
when it's dying but that trap washed up
on the beach you can't let the lobster
out not saying steal it and put it in my
car but even somebody would be
prohibited from letting the lobster out
and putting it back in the water rather
they'd have to slowly watch it bake to
death in the Sun
until somebody came along to deal with
it that owned the Trap it's kind of a
situation that we need to come to a
better grip on in the future but at this
point it's obvious that um
something needs to be done and if we
don't accede to the Senate's position
with this amendment uh demanding action
from the fish and game department
with a plan by September 30th that
[Music]
um
we aren't going to get anything done
because it'll just die and we'll get no
steps forward
so
um with that I will uh move that we
accede to the Senate's position
and um with the amendment being drafted
and and we'll give you the lead on that
drafting Senator Pearl we'll take care
of that and I'm going to ask for uh a
vote of my my committee here
um
I'll ask you uh each and turn my in turn
I guess Tom
yeah
I'll reluctantly see the amended Senate
sadly also as I stated earlier in the
question I asked earlier I just still do
not comprehend the current law any
inability as you said well put that
these animals will just have to die
whether they're underwater with a
detached rope or balled up on the beach
baking in the sun makes no sense to me
but I also agree with you that uh it
seems like we have a solid impasse so to
try to get something done before the
filing period for next year I will join
you
thank you all right representative Hill
like to see the headlines
and you will accede Iola seed
and representative pair
that's the best we can do that's the
best we can do I will see
thank you
um we will get the amendment drafted and
then it will be prepared for sign off uh
in the clerk's office and we're going to
need a blurb from our side
okay
all right thank you all
have a good rest of your day
hey everybody good afternoon it is two
o'clock we're gonna open up the
committee of conference hearing on HB 75
as currently amended by
1552 relative to the election of
Stratford County Commissioners
like to open up the floor to any
comments let's start with Senator gray
since
I'm the one who did the amendment that
uh uh originally just for background we
got three bills from the house uh I was
very concerned that I wasn't going to
get a budget from the house so I
Consolidated those three bills into one
bill which left 75 and I think it was 87
if I'm correct Senator Susie
um that uh
you know would be disposed of if we
didn't need them for the budget I was
asked by a constituent because the there
is a bill that originated in the house
um to start using districts in Stratford
County which would make it consistent
with the other nine counties to do that
uh so I took the bill that was in the
house uh put it on an amendment had a
public hearing on it uh and that's how
we are here today during that process uh
I did several different uh
Arrangements based on comments that I
heard made them available to various
people in the county including the
County Administrator who's the one who
talked to me most about this
um including a map that uh had
the County Commissioners in separate
districts from where they live right now
um the map that was originally in the
House Bill had two of the Commissioners
in the same district because the awards
that they lived in the ward in Dover
Ward 2 and Rollinsford about each other
so again I looked at it for the
constituents told them if they could get
some support that I would change the
layout that was on the map that I was
presenting uh at the hearing
um and even afterward uh I got no
response back from that so I went with
the map that was in the house bill
and that's what has been passed
again from comments that I've received
via one of the lobbyists uh I again went
and did the map
that would put the County Commissioners
in separate districts
it has
a couple of detractors it has us down to
one point where the uh
Warden Dover I think it is in whichever
Town it is butting up against each other
in just one point but that is still
legal but it has a very good deviation
of 5.5 percent from the highest positive
to the highest negative which is a good
deviation when you're looking at making
the populations equal especially in the
maps that I've done so that's where we
are today right now the thing in front
of us is the
bill as the house did it we passed that
in the Senate it went back to you I am
certainly willing if uh one of the
Democrats uh on the Committees would
like to present uh the other map that
I've done
um certainly willing to have that
presented uh copies are available for
all of the people here on the committee
conference
um and uh we'll continue with the
discussions very good Center and just
for the clarification of everybody at
the table Senator gray is talking about
uh Amendment 2023 2211 s
that is not what is currently
up for discussion but as Senator gray
mentioned if there's somebody a Democrat
who would like to put forward that
amendment We'd be open to hearing that
and I am not hearing that is there any
other discussion
I will say that when
this uh
Senator Gray's Amendment that's on the
table right now came to the house it
went through what I can only describe as
a some schizophrenic voting uh the
original motion to approve or to concur
with the Senate failed by two or three
votes uh the sub subsequent votes
actually prevailed by three votes that's
how we ended up here
so uh Senator Susie did I see you
wanted to say that I appreciate the work
that Senator gray has done in being open
to to looking at these districts I still
find myself wondering why having been a
member of the redistricting process and
having gone to the hearing in Stratford
County
where
Not only was there no mention of the
commissioner districts
but the complaints about the house
district
s are things that are being done in both
versions of these Maps which is
land areas that are barely contiguous
and splitting up the cities and I think
the fact that the cities are being split
up is part of the reason why the
delegation as a whole regardless of the
makeup hasn't brought this forward
geographically Stratford is one of the
smallest counties there's always a
contention between cities and towns
um you know I happen to live in
Manchester Manchester and Bedford are
part of one commissioner District but
that was a plan that Hillsborough County
brought forward and I still remain
concerned that this is
in my view and I'm just going to say
this this is a partisan move to change
these districts and the fact that we
were asked if a Democrat wanted to bring
one map forward or it should be a
Committee Member and I I guess I still
struggle with the process that brings us
here and I know that regardless of what
we do today in January your bill
representative will still have to have a
vote before the body and your bill
attempts to do something similar in
redistricting the county so I I'm just
not prepared today to
um
to vote affirmatively on either versions
of the maps at this time
thank you for that representative stavis
thank you representative turcotte and um
I have a couple of concerns which is the
reason I did not offer to move this
amendment forward and one primarily is
the process concern in Municipal and
County government of which I am the
ranking member we make changes to how
counties do their business all the time
it's our routine
MO
in our committee but we do we don't do
changes like this one
we um usually hear from multiple
Representatives who have been approached
by
10 or 20 constituents from both sides of
the aisle all sides of the aisle who
want to have Commissioners elected at
large they want them elected by District
they want this they want that
and we then have a hearing and we hear
from all sides we didn't have that with
HB 270 and that is why we voted to
retain it in the house so I'm still kind
of stuck on thinking about House Bill
270 and the fact that it was retained
and then all of a sudden appeared almost
exactly in identical format in a Senate
bill I would like our committee to
continue to work on this bill to
continue to consult with all
stakeholders in this issue and arrive at
a well-informed decision
later this year
Senator Gray
um
trying to respond to some of the things
out there um
uh House Bill 270 did get a hearing in
the house
house bill 75 and the amendment from 270
did get a hearing in the Senate it
followed the normal standard procedures
that that we have you know in
um the continued uh you know making the
uh
map up or certainly uh there is
conflicting things whether I'm going you
know how how much of a border I have to
share between one town and another uh
and equal population uh certainly when
we look at County Commissioners in the
State Constitution and other
documentation there is no real
guidelines about anything
uh nine of the counties
um do it by electing people by District
okay let me clarify that okay two of
them you have to live in the district
but they vote County Wide for the
positions and the others they all have
to live and are voted on by the people
in that District Stratford county is the
only one that didn't
I have lived in Stratford County or it's
been my residence because the time I was
in the service and and the uh I have
kept my my residence in New Hampshire uh
since 1964. okay I have never known
anything other than County Commissioners
being elected you know by countywide
okay so you know if you want to say
something why I didn't bring it up well
I've never known anything different I've
never really investigated the different
counties okay
but nine of them
are same one is different okay
constituents came to me said hey this
thing is stalled we'd like to move it
along we think it's stalled because of
the close separation between the
Democrats and the Republicans and the
house committee okay
I'm responding to my constituents health
and public hearing did the work and
passed the bill
if it is not to their liking
remember we had I think it was one or
two opposed and three or four four in
the in the senate committee and it was
publicized beforehand in fact I made
sure that the the rankings Democrat on
the senate election law committee knew
about it
um I think it was a week to week and a
half you know before
and it was actually the same day the
constituent had contacted me you know so
I couldn't do it any sooner
okay
the constituents in the smaller towns
want to be represented if you look at
the things that are happening Ward 5 in
Rochester and when we did the state
representative districts
they were complaining because they were
grouped with Middleton Milton okay
why because they want the representation
as close to the people as you can
electing County Commissioners countywide
is not getting that representation as
close to the people as you can using
districts like the other nine counties
do
this is how you do that
and to say we ought to wait
why
we have a map in front of us it got a
majority vote in the Senate
it
didn't get a
majority vote one way or the other in
the house
there are also people that say well hey
you had your shot at redistricting
this is a separate Grace
we have not redistricted we have not
districteded we have not done anything
with Stratford County
and if we look back to the Supreme Court
decisions about when the Supreme Court
did the districting 10 11 years ago
whatever it is now they said okay
this the house and the Senate have not
weighed in and have not redistricted so
they can we can pass another map
because we still have our opportunity
once in the 10 years
that's one legal argument the other
legal argument is this is districting
not redistricting
so with that
I you know I'm I'm happy with the the
map in 270 that we put into the bill
uh but if you know to make its thing
more partisan if I can get somebody else
that has a different map
and the only one I know is out there is
the one that I drew you know at the
request of the administrator of
Stratford County that says can I draw a
map that meets the criteria
and it puts the three existing County
Commissioners in separate districts
I went and did it and I passed it out
if you want it support it if you don't
want it
then we'll take the vote on the map from
270.
thank you
thank you Senator uh representative
lasalles
thank you Mr chairman uh I think when
you look at a case like this I've heard
arguments that and Senator gray touched
on it when he said that why are we
redistricting in the middle of the
stream we're not redistricting we're
making the initial districts anytime you
have a situation like this
where
all of the Commissioners are elected
on an at-large basis the minority is
Left Behind and if you look at
at the history of the county you'll see
that the minority has been left behind
Time After Time After Time and after a
while the people who are in the minority
figure out that they've been
disenfranchised and nobody cares whether
they've been disenfranchised so they
lose faith in the political system I've
heard people say that this is too
political of course it's political it's
inherently political it's political
subdivisions so I I think overall the
map that that is attached to to
this amendment uh works for me and I
know that anytime you have situations
like this there are negative aspects but
I think this is a much better the people
particularly in the rural areas of the
county are much better represented than
they have been in the past
thank you
representative save us thank you Mr
chair
so I I keep hearing a couple of
different things so I'm hoping someone
can educate me
I'm hearing that people have lost faith
in the political process and so they
didn't bother to do anything and to
change the situation I've also heard
that for years and years and years this
has been the case and this process has
been and I'm using someone else's words
here stalled
and I'm looking at HB 54 which has been
enacted it was enacted in November of
2021 so not years and years and years
ago but just barely two years ago
and that was a redistricting bill
that was presumably worked on by the
redistricting committee
and it said nothing about Stratford
County it made no changes at all so if
this has been going on for years and
years and years and people have felt
disenfranchised why wasn't it not
addressed then
thank you for the comments seeing no
more I will make several comments I'll
start by addressing the issue on HP 54.
I was a member of the special committee
on redistricting in the house and one of
our
given duties was to redistrict the
commissioner's Maps
it was brought to the attention of the
committee as a whole
that
from myself that it was the time that we
should redistrict
the Commissioners just or
District the in Stratford County for the
commissioners
I was told by
individuals on that committee that they
did not want to infuse an extra
uh
something that would muddy the waters
during the commissioner's redistricting
that's why it wasn't done I've made that
comment dozens of times now I've made it
on the house floor I've made that
comment in several newspapers that's the
reason why it wasn't done for no other
reason I brought it to the attention the
committee the committee as a whole said
it's too much we've got too much to do
our data's almost six to eight months
behind we don't have time we're not
going to put that into the mix that's
the answer to that
um I Heard a comment about combining
Wards with towns you cannot
District Stratford County
with all cities intact it's impossible
because of the deviation requirements it
cannot be done
you will require
Ward to be combined with the town and
that's not unusual in the commissioner
Maps
that happens throughout the state
especially when you cut when you're
talking about the state representative
Maps you go through those I'm very very
very familiar with you go through and
you'll find in almost every County or at
least half the counties you will see
where Wards are combined with towns for
the specific reason you have to meet
deviation requirements which are have
been for the most part a 10 deviation in
all the U.S Supreme Court cases
um
why are we doing this now why was it
retained
I got a laugh on the house floor last
week when I said it was retained by a
mistaken vote and that is a fact a
member of our committee made the wrong
vote
after several other votes
to retain
and that's where it is and it's stuck
and we can't get it out of there that is
why Senator gray took up and put the
contents of HB 270
into HB 75
this bill
as Senator gray mentioned there are
different ways that Commissioners get
elected in our state
in each of the nine each of the ten
counties as he said and I'll reiterate
nine of the counties have districts
Stratford county is the only one
that does not
this map would bring us if you want to
look for a analogy we would mirror how
Hillsborough County elects their
commissioners
exactly the same
during our as a member of the special
committee on redistricting we went
around to every County I think I made
seven of the ten and to hear input on
the three maps that we were responsible
State reps the U.S house rep
and the Commissioners met
we probably heard from him let's call it
150 maybe 200 different people who spoke
do you know how many individuals spoke
up about a commissioner's map
not a single one
not one
last thing I will say is by default I
hear the word those very unfamiliar with
redistricting in the process and
everything that goes into the
redistricting process
they like to look at a map and Oh that's
gerrymandered oh the process is
gerrymandered
most people who talk about Jeremy don't
have a clue what actual gerrymandering
is
I think I could make a very very strong
argument
that right now as Strafford County has
been for the last 40 years
is gerrymandered by by default just by
the who gets elected constantly
so with that
um once again I'll open it up if anybody
wishes to make an amendment or introduce
an amendment I'll accept that if we
don't we'll proceed on from here
and not seeing anybody so
um I understand we got to take a house
vote and Senate vote
go ahead senator
thanks Senator all those in favor of the
house
members of the House who are in favor of
the existing HP 75 as amended by 1552
say aye aye
all those opposed say no or thank you
that is three to one so uh with that we
will close the committee a conference on
each the 75 as amended by 1552
and I'll have the committee Court
committee report drawn up thank you
foreign